you know what show you I mean you would
like it cuz you used to watch football
but uh the Hard Knocks is back and it's
[ __ ] good and there's star receiver
Antonio Brown who's the best receiver in
the league he's always like had a
troubled past he's a diva he gets there
and he refuses to play because he has he
said first he went into one of those
cold chambers without the socks you just
went in barefoot you always have to have
booties on there's a reason for that so
he got like you know frostbite all over
his bottom of his feet Jesus so he can't
run and now he the NFL has new helmets
right so to like make concussions not as
bad and he doesn't want to use it he
wants use his old helmet so they're like
no I used the new helmet so now he's not
playing because he's not wearing a
helmet
he's they're only five receivers always
been give this oh he's such a monster
it's so fast oh just so goddamn good
crazy though crazy but that the the Hard
Knocks is pretty great but the problem
is is the coach on their Gruden he
cusses a ton you know and it's so
censored you know the way Hard Knocks
shoots at HBO the team sees it before it
releases because they don't want
anything get out that they don't want
out into the public so they tell you
what to cut out and they make Gruden's
seem like a [ __ ] faint but he is a
[ __ ] he's a sailor dude oh my god
he's as hard on these quarterbacks but
he's a just editing was back coaching oh
yeah he didn't want to do now he's back
for the Raiders but they edit it like
he's like good job buddy keep it up and
it's like come on man it'd be so much
better if they showed the real yeah this
one's a bucket he's so awesome yeah he's
great I thought he didn't want these
guys get sucked back into it though yeah
how could you not what would Bill
Parcells is doing is he an owner of
anything or a manager no I don't think
so and what's crazy is that you got show
on Netflix last chance you on the first
season there's a kid from that you know
they take like rejects from like
Division one stuff they go to Community
College and there's that last chance you
there's a kid from there who's a stud
but he's lazy and then you see him on
hard Luck's he get because he you went
to somewhere like Alabama and now you
got
shot on the Raiders and cuz he was lazy
at the Community College and then you
see him in the NFL camp and I was
telling my girl a Mike I'm like cuz she
shooting like football she likes last
chance you and hard knocks and she goes
oh that's the guy who kept [ __ ] up in
Community College ago watch what happens
if he tries that man I fell she goes
water you just watch watch if he even
hiccups wrong we'll see what happens so
there it's the like the first week at
camp and they're in the dog days you
know and he goes I'm like my foots
killing me and that he's like well yeah
push do it amazing no I can't go they go
oh cool they kind of literally like they
cut him like see ya
just shows them taking his jersey out
there not like see ya my girls like what
the [ __ ] I'm like oh no they don't play
they don't give a [ __ ] yes she you're
not drafted yeah you just you're playing
dad how it is or my wrap it up or do
whatever you have to do what are you
doing
it's your shot like you have such a
short leash and then you could have
battled through it but he's been so like
got some rise head and like surprise now
I told him like watch what happens when
he tries in the NFL I'm sorry but Gruden
goes let's get these guys gonna play the
[ __ ] out of here and literally an hour
later he's not I'm playing back though
you know it's it's not a popular thing
to say but for the most part I'm gonna
say 90 set I'm older now 97% of the time
when you see somebody who's not doing
well or doing really well it's a hundred
percent their fault ten percent I don't
give a [ __ ] boy you know I'm sure lots
of things happened I'm sure you did what
you see is that these are patterns of
behavior and patterns of behavior or
have it's a habit it's a habit it's a
little bit like when somebody says that
guy's a pedophile what but then you see
it's not just one kid it's a history of
it it's 50 kids all yeah I mean you know
these are these are patterns of behavior
that I've been repeating themselves
forever and your choices are always
shitty like he got dealt with though he
learn real quick see ya bye bye machan
teaches but here's what here's like
Gruden says inside he opens the show
with this he goes he goes here's the
thing he goes you got
to end somebody's dream you gotta take
the job you gotta take their heart you
guys clear about the NFL it's the NFL
that's exactly right you're literally
put like it's not a team thing like you
gotta take that soap is this is no
different always like this like this hey
what what happened your whole family
died in the fire so it's bad next it's
called next though we don't need you
would you just move out of the way I'm
sorry that whatever happened whatever it
will happen
we got too many people waiting in line
well it doesn't matter that doesn't care
life is that by month no that becomes
your young and Miss ladies that way next
Tommy's the exact same horse it is I was
talking to the guys last night at Bray
and they're saying so while it got up
there here it is up here they're saying
this guy was mad because on the marquee
they put an older picture of not a newer
picture and put him on this side not
this side and he sold 60 tickets for six
shows and they do cancel the show and he
blame them like no it's never the cut
it's never ever so ever blame anybody
like that no I don't blame anybody it's
the picture you put a picture of a fight
you could picture of Harvey Weinstein
say jokowi's then he's gonna sell out 16
shows it doesn't matter man yeah a joke
earnings at yes he earned that shows
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]